again this in a way is an excuse like
with that women use because if he hasn't
seen a therapist and he hasn't been
professionally diagnosed you can't
diagnose him as a narcissist I think
it's difficult because I know it's not
it's not difficult you know it's like if
he if he's not hasn't been diagnosed as
a narcissist we can't just go around
calling people narcissists so I'm gonna
say narcissistic traits what that means
is that a person is coming across a
certain way where they're not diagnosed
I apologize if anyone paying offense to
that I think I want to answer Paul's
question
um with regards to what are the mistakes
women make
um in becoming web so I think personally
today's women think that identifying
with feminism is a good long-term
strategy
and it's clearly not because
as you said men appreciate youth men
appreciate fertility so I think the
biggest problem with feminism for me is
that
feminism encourages Independence right
and in today's society for females
Independence means in my opinion
incredibly promiscuous so they end up
sleeping with multiple guys figuring to
do the same thing as men because
normally independence mean you can do
what you want right by yourself
but it's clearly not working out for
anyone I mean suppose all the statistics
about
I mean what age are women getting
married now what age are women having
kids now like it's not working out for
women at all so go ahead can I mention
that that video I mean
the is that a big deal like what they
were mentioning you're exaggerating like
the light thing like come on
what if it was like let me just try to
guess it's gonna concentrated stuff yeah
that's the issue
yeah like the point is that girls make
every sob story out of everything I
don't understand why that's a sub I'm
sorry I might be a bit slow but I
genuinely don't understand and then but
you see the men you see the men enabling
them too yeah because the manner the men
are saying oh like all you have to do is
be nice to a girl but it's funny because
the girl the second guy the girl was
just using like she was using for
attention he walked away after the date
then she wanted the attention got a set
like got another date out of him and
then it was like uh see this where we
have to speak about remember this is
where we have to speak about men a bit
because I think men
I think there's a lot of delusional men
too as much as um this probably the only
bit I'll stick up for me so I might as
well get out of the way now
um I've seen men in just just going out
nightclubs and such I've seen men get
upset when they can't get the baddest
girl in the club and I'm looking at them
thinking like what do you what are you
what what's what are you like are you an
average looking dude for starters do you
have swag do you have money and you're
upset that you can't get the baddest go
in a club like
it's like yeah there's a lot of
delusional men too I can't just throw it
all on women I've seen many things in my
life like I'm just looking at dude like
you're not gonna get that short I got a
question for you son sure you mentioned
earlier you like to bring up to um to
women you know just look in the mirror
right or I'm not sure about down south
but where I'm from up North most of the
women and I'm sure anyone from the north
would agree with me I ratchet right and
um if you even start to bring up
accountability they will fly off the
handle and it will not end well for you
know like even if you put your foot down
they'll throw a pun at your head you
know what I mean so they're crazy so
what what would be your advice for the
you have to draw women they're crazy I
can give you the quick strategy but I I
know how to oh I gotta show you hey go
ahead go ahead I can give you that I
can't give any guy that's watching how
to get a girl in a nightclub anyway if
you want to know that like okay this is
the most simplest method that's worked
for me when I was single by the way so
I got more for example I do me and my
friends do this [__] all the time right
so you see a girl that you're attracted
to at the bar right
I woke up there's a there's a long queue
I use my structure I use my stance I use
myself I'm not gonna walk right to the
front and be like you got what are you
guys drinking I'll tell you when to
drink I said cool no worries don't say
another word right
go to the bar ordered my drink all that
damaging
give it to them and walk off
and I I promise you yeah the amount of
times them same girls think what the
fighting awesome for my number he didn't
ask for my Snapchat what the hell I
literally go cool walk off here they
find you that same night because you're
you're you you're making them think
you're adding you're adding some sort of
like doubt in the world why no speaking
why ain't ask for my number like just
walk off and then obviously there's got
to be something about you though I don't
want to tell like some any dude you can
just do this and it's going to be
successful like you have to have
something about you like me and my
friends we're very [__] we go out all
over the UK we're simple we get a table
VIP that's it because as we know
American culture UK culture they
appreciate women appreciate that but it
depends on your goal they're trying to
find a wifey that's one thing you're
trying to have fun that night that's
another thing but
I think when men give it all out on the
table there and then women are not
interested because they know that what
they can get from there and it's like
even even the one guy in the reaction
video he said like just don't touch her
yeah
the last two videos in that uh that
video The Tick Tock videos was guys
basically ignoring them and the ladies
were like I've never been more attracted
in my life yeah so uh it's just you
always want what you can't have that's
why what what are the most ridiculous
standards that you've heard men and
women say men and women yeah so so give
me like it doesn't have to be that high
maybe you haven't heard one that's that
high for one or the other but for a man
to like wife a girl and for a girl to
White to marry a guy what are like the
highest standards you've heard a girl
and a guy say
um well uh one of them has got to be a
single mother talking to me and saying
like oh I want this I want this I want
this out of a guy specifically
um you know just having money having a
car uh having his own house and you know
accommodate yeah how old was she she was
like my age 19. she want to do with the
house yeah yeah so um and maybe she
wasn't on about right now but regardless
no matter the age it's it's very rarely
gonna happen unless if you're gonna find
a simp okay right and we all know how
that's gonna end now what about the most
picky guy you know uh the most picky guy
um
I don't really think I know that many
people
okay okay fair enough go ahead dude I'll
start off with the guys I know some guys
that are very picky and they don't have
the qualities to be that picky so I've
heard guys like 30 plus talking about my
girl can't have more than three buddies
my girl car more than four buddies and
I'm like
I mean first of all what are you
offering you still live at your mom's
crib like have you got your own paper
like your own crib no so how are you
asking a girl you're trying to find the
girls when you got free bodies what does
that mean how much would have had sex
with you uh for women I mean I've seen
some bang average looking women talk
about I want a guy that's got six
figures I want a guy that's got his own
Crypt and they're like if my guy's still
living at his mom's house at 22 29 I
don't want and I'm looking I'm thinking
right okay what do you have to offer
I think I'm very blessed that I surround
myself with wonderful people and I'll be
very honest from a personal level I have
I see many beautiful examples of
relationships that work really really
well men and women so for me I it would
just be quoting things on the internet
to be honest so you've never heard
anyone in real life have a super am I
because I have high standards of people
that I surround myself with so that's
why so no answer okay right pretty much
the usual like six figure and all that
stuff but the craziest one I had was the
the 200k engagement ring oh from not
just oh I forgot about it oh yeah oh my
Lord she literally wants a house on her
finger I can't imagine that that's just
the engagement ring that's not even the
wedding no I'm cheap you see so I just
couldn't imagine even if I had the money
I would never spend tutor can an
engagement ring and I was actually
thinking about it today this morning
like a girl is advertising so she wants
a man who can afford that but then
doesn't she respect him like
she doesn't connect you could tour
Europe and see all of Europe India like
you could go all around the world for
200k you're gonna spend that on a rain
yeah in a small a smart guy who was made
that money by himself is not going to
spend that money at all on a ring that
is the that is the worst investment as a
businessman you could make it's just not
worth it so she gains his Respect by
building this wealth and then she loses
it like he loses the respect by making
such a bad word oh what if she lost the
ring
oh my God
oh my God I don't even like wearing
expensive jewelry can we talk about in
London I genuinely had to tell one of my
friends from Hong Kong who has a big-ish
ring for UK standards which is not big
for us but big for UK and I actually
told her to please can you swing your
ring around because you are going to get
your finger chopped off yeah you don't
know it's it's like why are you she was
traveling why are you wearing this wear
it at home but I was I personally think
that people are like they just think
they they're doing it for their ego so
they want to look flashy they want to
look amazing right usually these people
are broke by the way because they spend
it they spend it all on stuff that they
then wear rather than put it in their
wealth and then they and then they they
cry when they get mugs they get robbed
like
well you're the one who's literally
advertising yourself to unfortunately in
a certain way and
girls don't like hearing that you if you
dress a certain way you're gonna attract
a certain type of attention the same
breath say uh I can protect myself and I
don't need a man that's the problem
because if you get if you're a female
you get robbed you're the first person
you've been a cool